there was talk that back in the early
like 2011 ish that you worked on the the
the live-action Star Wars series that
Lucas was trying to get off the ground
is there any truth to that yeah I was
one of several there were there was a
bunch of international writers they
assembled internationally and we would
gather up at Skywalker Ranch
you know once every six to eight weeks
something like that and we would break
stories together and then we'd go off
and write some drafts and bring them
back and George and we would sit down
and critique them and do another draft
and the great more stories and yeah I
mean it went on for a year or something
like that you're in half it was great it
was a ball it was a lot of fun it was a
didn't it didn't happen ultimately we we
wrote I'd say somewhere in the 40
something 48 scripts something like that
George wanted the theory was George
wanted to write all the scripts and get
them all done and then he was gonna go
off and figure out how to produce them
because he wanted to do a lot of you
know cutting-edge technological stuff
with CG and virtual sets and so on so he
had a whole new thing he wanted to
accomplish and what happened was you
know we wrote the scripts and then
George said okay this is enough for now
and then I'll get back to you I want to
look into all the production things and
the time went by and like you know a
year or something after that is when he
sold Lucasfilm to Disney so I think he
just decided yeah it was the confluence
of those events of either getting into
this giant new Star Wars live-action TV
show or somehow you know he just decided
to sell to sell the whole the whole kit
and kaboodle around the same period it's
pretty crazy
I mean you've worked in TV a long time
and I've learned so much about the
production of television nobody has 48
scripts written before you're gonna
start producing something it's crazy
yeah it's kind of it's kind of nuts it
was an extraordinary sort of you know
undertaking for someone to do I don't
know anyone else that would really take
that on obviously I'm sure do you think
at the time I always heard that the
technology like the scripts were just
too advanced for the technology that
exists
and I look at stuff like the mandalorian
now and what they're doing with these
virtual sets do you think that the
technology has caught up to what you
guys wrote on the page do you think it's
like scripts that could still be used in
the future or do you think that's just
you know it was sort of a time in a
place and who knows what's gonna happen
well it's hard to say because you know
certainly we've come a long way with
virtual sets and CG technology in the
mean time at the time George just said
write them as big as you want we'll
figure it out later so we really had no
constraints I mean we were all
experienced television and feature
writers so we all kind of knew what was
Fioretti possible on a production budget
but we just went for this past he said
okay let's just take him at his word
that should make it crazy and big it was
lots of action and lots of sets and huge
set pieces and just much bigger than
what you would normally do anything in a
television show and we knew that at some
point it wasn't gonna have to dial back
so I don't know that specifically there
were only things we were trying to
accomplish that you couldn't could or
could not accomplish with today's
technology it just we didn't we hadn't
really focus on any production issues at
the time that we wrote the original
drafts my last question for you about
this because I'm very curious when you
guys were writing were you writing with
like 10 episode arcs or 20 episode arcs
or was it one big 48 episode storyline
it was pretty much I mean yeah I think
it was pretty much one big storyline it
was one long one long tale with episodic
you know things that would happen
there'd be you know certain events would
happen in this episode or this episode
so it was sort of an episodic quality to
some of it but it was telling a larger
narrative in terms of the story of those
particular characters in that setting